hi in this video we'll talk about does
intermittent fasting induces autophagy
or not
intermittent fasting is a time
restricted feeding pattern which has
plethora of health benefit it can help
you to lose weight it is good for
increasing lifespan it can be beneficial
for people who are suffering from
cardiac disease it help you to
deal with stress efficiently increases
your cognitive cognitive abilities and
also it helps in management of diabetes
if you want to learn more about the
clinical benefits then you can click on
the video which is in the i button
in this video we'll talk about whether
intermittent fasting can induce
autophagy or not but before that we need
to understand what is autophagy
autophagy it's kind of like a cellular
garbage clearing mechanism it's kind of
like a recycle mechanism
intrinsic to the cells
and that is really beneficial
autophagy gains it popularity when it
was awarded nobel prize in 2016.
yoshinoro yoshumi was awarded the nobel
prize in physiology and medicine for
discovery of the mechanisms of autophagy
now autophagy is proven to be really
beneficial from a health point of view
and in this video we'll talk about
whether intermittent fasting can induce
the autophagy indeed it does
so let's talk about it in bit more
details autophagy is a process in which
cell eats its own components
and the greek word auto means self and
fiji means eating so inside the cell
there could be some damaged organelles
there could be damaged proteins and
other enzymes
which is engulfed by the autophagic
vesicle and thereby it is degraded in
the autophagosome
and it's kind of like a recycled
mechanism
so autophagy is evolutionary conserved
and it's kind of like a
way by which it can help
organisms to recycle nutrients and use
it
when it is needed
so let's take an example of that imagine
you are starving and starving creates a
stressed situation for your body because
you don't get enough amount of nutrient
for the metabolic purposes of the body
so it's a stressed environment
so how autophagy is useful in this
process let me tell you how
so
under any situation there are a lot of
non-functional proteins inside our cell
so when the body is not getting
nutrients from outside it would look for
non-functional degraded
proteins inside and it would break it
down and salvage it for production of
new proteins
and that is how autophagy is really
really beneficial studies have shown
that autophagy is evoked after 24 hours
of fasting and it peaks if you fast for
48 hours
that means even after
taking a meal you have to wait for 24
hours patiently in order to evoke
autophagy question is whether it is
worth it or not
and i'll say completely it is important
because let's say there is a uh i mean
you need to produce functional enzyme
under a stressed environment because
every time our body need to function it
needs all these enzymes proteins
molecules inside the body
for our metabolism to go on
but under the stressed environment
we need
like proteins but we don't have amino
acids coming from food
because at this point of time we are
starving so we don't have any food right
so dietary amino acids cannot be
utilized to generate new proteins so how
how does body manage to get amino acids
the answer is simple body breaks down
existing protein using the autophagy and
in this process it not only
breaks down the proteins but also
recycle non-functional proteins and
proteins which are kind of harmful
and in simple word it it's kind of like
a detox activity
there are many cases
like alzheimer's disease where there are
misfolded proteins now
theoretically autophagy can also recycle
these misfolded proteins break them down
and help the body to generate new
proteins from this garbage
that is how autophagy could be really
beneficial for improving
cognitive health and overall health
now researchers has proven that
autophagy has
uh implications in terms of aging and
health
but before that let me tell you that
which intermittent fasting paradigm is
the best for inducing autophagy because
there are so many intermittent fasting
paradigm in market like time restricted
feeding five is to two diet eat stop
heat pattern alternate day fasting and
the warrior diet among them the most
beneficial one is the alternate day
fasting where you eat normally in a
particular day and the next day you fast
you take very low calorie or almost no
calories and you repeat this pattern
throughout the week this is called as
alternate day fasting that means in this
process your body goes through a cycle
of metabolic switching sometimes your
body is evoking autophagy when you while
you're fasting
and then it has a plenty of nutrients
it's building your overall body and
takes care of the metabolism
now the most popular
intermittent fasting pattern which is a
18 is to 6 intermittent fasting
doesn't really help that much in terms
of
inducing autophagy because
18 hours
or like 16 is to eight fasting
or even other time restricted feeding
patterns are not prolonged enough
to
uh induce autophagy
so all these other time restricted
feeding warrior diet all of that has
other benefits such as it would help you
to lose weight gain other insulin
resistance and all of these things would
be there but
the autophagy would be only induced if
you fast for long enough
now these evidences come from
worldwide and there are many tribes such
as centenaries in the okinawa island
hunza tribe in pakistan
and there are other tribes in andes who
lived over 100 years
and why one thing was common in their
diet that was periodic fasting was
incorporated in their daily ritual so
people think that
daily i mean periodic fasting boosts
autophagy which helps you to age slowly
increases your lifespan and it also
evoke the resilience towards many
diseases so i hope this video was useful
there are now tons and tons of evidence
that autophagy and caloric restriction
can induce or help
due while aging it can slow down aging
it can also increase lifespan so all
these links are provided in this
description you can take a look at it hi
so i hope this is useful if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
thank you